E aí, você toma a litanina só quando tá
nervoso ou nervosa ou antes de uma
reunião importante? Então, um estudo
publicado em 2024 Neurology and
Therapeutics mostrou que quem usou
LTanina por 28 dias consecutivos teve
resultados bem diferentes e quem usou
apenas de forma pontual. A redução no
estresse percebido foi de quase 18%. E
não foi só o stresse que melhorou. A
qualidade de sono mudou de uma forma que
talvez você não esteja esperando. Nos
próximos minutos eu vou te mostrar
exatamente o que a ciência descobriu
sobre o uso contínuo desse aminoácido e
porque a forma como você está usando
pode estar limitando os seus resultados.
Aiteanina é um aminoácido encontrado
naturalmente nas folhas do chá verde.
Diferente de calmantes convencionais,
ela não causa sedação, você não fica
abobalhado. O que ela faz é promover um
estado de relaxamento alerta. E aqui
está o ponto que a maioria das pessoas
não entende. Quando você toma a
liteanina de forma pontual, tipo um
comprimido antes de uma apresentação no
trabalho, você tá usando ela como
extintor de incêndio. Vai funcionar?
Sim. Um estudo de 2021 mostrou que uma
dose única de 200 mg aumentou sim as
ondas alfas cerebrais na região frontal
após 3 horas. Essas ondas alfa estão
associadas àquela situação de estado de
calma focada. O cortisol salivá também
caiu significativamente uma hora após a
dose. Então sim, o uso agudo tem o seu
lugar, mas aqui vem a parte que muitos
não te contam. O uso pontual é como
colocar um bandeid e uma ferida que
precisa de estrutura. Se o seu problema
é estresse crônico, aquele estresse do
dia a dia que nunca vai embora, uso
ocasional não vai resolver a raiz do
problema. E foi exatamente isso que os
pesquisadores quiseram investigar no
estudo de 2024. Eles recrutaram 30
adultos saudáveis entre 18 e 65 anos que
tinham estresse moderado. Não eram
pessoas com transtornos psiquiátricos,
eram pessoas normais, como eu e você,
que vivem com aquela carga de estresse
que parece fazer parte da vida moderna.
metade recebeu 400 mg de eliteanina por
dia durante 28 dias e a outra metade
recebeu placebo e os resultados foram
bem interessantes. Após duas semanas, o
grupo da liteanina já mostrava a redução
de quase 13% na escala de estresse
percebido. Após 4 semanas, a redução foi
a 18%.
Mas o que me chamou mais atenção foi o
que aconteceu com sono. O grupo que
tomou a liteanina teve uma redução
significativa no tempo de sono leve. E
isso é importante. Sono leve demais
significa que você não está atingindo as
fases mais reparadoras do sono. É aquela
sensação de dormir 8 horas e acordar
cansado. Outro dado fascinante desse
estudo foi a melhora na tensão
cognitiva. O grupo da LTAN melhorou mais
de 21% no teste Strup, que mede atenção
e capacidade de filtrar de extrações. E
essa melhora apareceu tanto em duas
semanas quanto em quatro semanas. O
grupo placebo só mostrou melhoria
significativa após quatro semanas, ou
seja, a liteanina acelerou o processo.
Agora você pode estar pensando, mas foi
só um estudo e eu concordo que um estudo
não faz verão. Por isso, vale mencionar
que pesquisadores japoneses fizeram um
estudo semelhante usando 200 mg por dia
durante 4ro semanas. Os resultados foram
na mesma direção. Redução, discórdia de
depressão, ansiedade, qualidade do sono.
E mais, houve melhora significativa na
latência do sono, que é o tempo que você
leva para pegar no sono e redução no uso
de medicação para dormir. Afuência
verbal e a função executiva também
melhoraram. Uma revisão sistemática
publicada em novembro de 25 analisou 13
ensaios clínicos com um total de 550
participantes. E qual foi a conclusão?
Doses entre 200 e 450 mg por dia parece
ser seguras e eficazes para dar suporte
ao sono saudável em adultos. Perceba que
eu estou falando de apoiar, não de
tratar insônia clínica, são coisas
diferentes. E como é que a liteanina faz
isso? O mecanismo é bem elegante. Ela
atravessa a barreira imatecefálica,
modula neurotransmissores como gaba,
serotonina, dopamina. Ao mesmo tempo,
ela aumenta a atividade de ondas alfa no
cérebro. É como se ela ajudasse seu
cérebro a sair do modo de luta ou fuga
sem te deixar sonulento. Você fica mais
calmo ou calma, mas continua bastante
funcional e produtivo. Agora vem a
pergunta prática. Qual estratégia vamos
utilizar? Se você tem um evento
estressante pontual, uma palestra, por
exemplo, você tem que dar falar em
público, uma dose única de 200 mg, cerca
de uma hora antes pode ajudar. Mas se o
seu problema é o estresse do dia a dia
que não te deixa em paz, considere um
protocolo de uso contínuo. Os estudos
usaram 200 a 400 mg por dia por pelo
menos 4 semanas. A maioria das pessoas
toma de manhã ou à tarde, já que a
liteanina não causa sonolência. Se o seu
objetivo principal é melhorar o sono,
alguns estudos mostram benefício em
tomar cerca de uma hora antes de dormir.
Uma combinação que aparece
frequentemente na literatura é litanina
com cafeína. Parece contraditório, mas a
litanina suaviza os efeitos colaterais
da cafeína, como ansiedade e
taquicardia, mantendo o benefício de
foco. Doses típicas são 100 a 200 mg de
eliteanina para cada 50 a 100 de
cafeína, mas isso é assunto para outro
vídeo. Sobre segurança, a literanina tem
um perfil excelente. Nos estudos de 28
dias, os únicos efeitos adversos
relatados foram gosto metálico e boca
seca em algumas pessoas classificados
como leves. Não houve alterações
significativas em exames laboratoriais
ou sinais vitais. A revisão sistemática
de 25 também confirmou a segurança em
dose de até 900 mg por dia em estudo de
suplementação. Uma dica bônus, um estudo
de 2024 combinou a liteanina com alfa S1
caseína, um peptídeo derivado do leite.
Eu sei, eu sei, você já me ouviu falar
muito mal da caseína, mas eu tô só
relatando o estudo. Essa combinação
aumentou o tempo total de sono em 45
minutos comparado ao placebo. Se você tá
buscando potencializar os efeitos, essa
é uma combinação que vale a pena dar uma
olhada, mas tome cuidado que não deve
ser a mesma caseína problemática do
leite comum que você bebe todos os dias.
Agora, uma verdade aqui no YouTube eu
preciso simplificar sobre LTanina. Eu
não posso, por exemplo, detalhar
combinações cinéticas específicas ou com
protocolos de doses mais altas para
ansiedade resistente. Na comunidade
fechada, eu compartilho o protocolo
completo de manejo do estresse com
aliteanina, combinado a magnésio,
estreonato, achanda, fossadiina,
além de combinações of label,
fornecedores confiáveis, interpretação
avançada de exames, temos lives
semanais, PDF com 47 protocolos
exclusivos, grupo no WhatsApp. Se você
quer a visão funcional real, clique em
seja membro. Já que estamos falando de
sono estresse, você precisa entender
como a luz solar pode ser a sua maior
aliada para regular o ciclo de
melatonina em cortisol. Assista esse
vídeo aqui sobre como usar a luz solar
para melhorar a saúde, sono e imunidade,
que vai complementar perfeitamente o que
você aprendeu hoje. Agradecimentos
especiais de coração aos nossos membros
queridos do Estudos Avançados da
comunidade fechada do YouTube. Começando
pelos novos membros que entraram
recentemente, Luciano Silva Paurinelli,
Luciano Elias, Lê Trigono, Juliana
Pontes, Carlos Rovi, Odonor Pinheiro,
Cíntia de Assis Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e
Fernando Machado. Sejam muito
bem-vindos. Agradeço também aos membros
que fizeram upgrade para os estudos
avançados. Irma, Iana, Antônio Renato,
Adriane, Dra. Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Murtinho, Soucioli, Cristina
Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela Mari
Silva, Elô Terapias, Luís Anselmo, muito
obrigado pela confiança em elevar o
nível de participação. Um abraço
especial aos membros que retornaram à
comunidade, Alex Caldas, Marcelo
Pimentel e Cláudio Leitão. Que bom ter
vocês de volta. Eu quero fazer um
reconhecimento especial aos membros mais
fiéis. Estela Mares com incríveis 56
meses de fidelidade. Dra. Ana Paula com
44 meses de participação, Marcelo
Pimentel com 23 meses e Antônio Renato
com 21 meses de história conosco. A
todos vocês eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado. você fazem a diferença
nessa comunidade.